hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Wade and we're Wade
and Bob hi how's it going guys hey good
I clapped you clapped for what for the
start of it ok good job everybody
congratulation for getting passed up
getting it again made you're so amazing
anyway we're here as you can tell things
look a little different from Lion I'm
playing or we're playing techid yeah um
which means that I couldn't use my old
texture packs or things look awful
especially when I'm living here in you
Wade
yeah good knotch I'm looking over to
never mind ok what we're gonna do is
we're gonna play a little bit of regular
Tekkit we got no um specific goal I kind
of want to go towards the goal of making
a nuke but I don't think we could do
that in five minutes you that I don't
even know you see I don't know cuz i've
got i've got all these i've got uh not
enough items installed but they updated
a lot of what tackett was about they did
huge updates detected it's it's
incredibly different right guys have you
played ticket in a while i haven't heard
in a while but i can already tell it's
very different just from starting off
okay and no Bob I'm not gonna give you a
nuke what we're gonna do is we need to
get started like a man yes we need to
get started like legitimately because we
need to UM we need to get uranium for
one thing and then we need to enrich you
it was wait didn't we build a nuke one
time oh we built a nuclear reactor that
you turned into a ñu but it wasn't quite
a nuke it just exploded that's all that
happened there we did do a livestream
one time where you kept nuking I think
me we kept nuking something I'm not sure
yeah I remember we look for the finale
like we did a bunch of nukes but anyway
what we're gonna do here is I'm gonna
start you guys off with some shovels
because I'm the only one right I'm the
only one that has superpowers yeah can
you guys see my Waypoint or is that just
for me oh just for you I just see mine
okay okay
okay we're gonna get here wait take this
shovel and pickaxe line
okay socket wait I've got it
okay cool fine by me um you're taking
take another one or you take one weight
fight over it fight over in my
maintenance yes haha wait I've got a
shovel just a shovel take a pick up I've
got everything else okay
alright we're good okay so we're all set
up and ready to grow grow ready to go oh
don't ask why I have so many beds in my
inventory then we should call this drunk
ticket part one and just like dude I'm
serious about no this is unrelated to
minecraft HP Bowl it is different if we
want to build complicated things we're
gonna do more than like two Episode
we're not gonna build we're gonna build
on our episodes too sir hey yo is going
I don't want to go down there no matter
what I'm at the end of this episode not
helping we're gonna have a new no
ethical but oh you need guys eat torches
right yeah well hey I'm we I you know I
could just be above you and dig straight
down and make holes oh my look I got a
hundred and eleven torches infinite
torches here uh I don't think it's not
quite infinite take infinite did you did
you get infinite torches I have thing
that says torch fifty torch fifty that
doesn't make any sense
wait what are you doing as our fellas on
torch what I gave you a bajillion
torches it's just one torch
uh uh I don't know I have infinite
torches
you want some torches wait yeah wait
we're going in the hole get in our hole
Oh buddy where our hole is um why does
it say torch 50 what what's wrong is it
special fifty kind of torch still place
it but it's not fesses crap ah what do
you do mark I don't know how about these
are these regular torches those are not
getting picked up what
those are torch 50 make your own damn
towards here's some call mean they're
gonna work it's the same difference
oh well you didn't say that I thought
you were like Luther work there torch
50s what are you doing - you guys all
right
oh oh oh you worried you can't see what
I'm drinking but we should show the
viewers yes we should I'm really proud
of mine today they already saw it haha
show them again and tell him what it is
so it's it's not just a bottle of gin it
was like ha ha ha
it was like like here uh ish and I
topped it off with sprite Diet Sprite
and Sierra Mist why would I be such a
pansy I'm drinking a horrible concoction
because everyone can see it's like it's
a cocktail called baby [ __ ] right baby
it's the worst shade of green you could
possibly see um this was originally
purple it was it was the mountain Dew
voltage and then I had a decent roto to
it and it just you could see like a
layer at the bottom that's just like
curd Brown and it tastes real good let
me tell you it's not special mmm are you
drinking white beer uh no actually it's
not it's a mixture of rum and vodka no
there's no beer you always drink it too
little sweet and sour mix because it's
kinda gross it just like you were like
awful wait gross I'm like tongue Oh
already we just started I'm are the
crops Kenickie fun gross like you Wayde
is our diamond diamonds already know you
probably didn't where are you we're not
low enough for diamonds weight searches
warts dust searches and searches court
they added a ton of stuff to tech it I
mean we could do like a whole Tekken
series if we really wanted to but we're
not gonna but who really wants to who
really wants to see that
we're not here to make any sort of
progress in the in the amazing
advancements of minecraft mod
we're here to be drunk and make fun of
Wade right well water
what oh wait it's oh I found a cave oh I
hear wanting to keep finding things
I don't know cuz there's a whole bunch
of new stuff
irbaz this game is not the fine stuff
ern found iron
hey there's lava up there I'm going up
lava
oh there's also copper I think yeah that
looks like huh
what's this [ __ ] now that everything new
I found a tunnel thingy whatever the Han
I got a I'm not gonna trust that much
we're obviously gonna be really good at
this game Bob find something new what's
the shot a dungeon I don't have a sword
oh you bad wicked Oh mark why not why it
was saying that number why
apparently it says the item number next
to everything that we have Oh dirty dies
yeah my iron pickaxe is 257 the copper
ores 925 Oh Catherine s Catherine that's
awfully convenient you know right like
800 zombies my sounds are wood that's
not true Aidan clearly not okay alright
so if you uh um we need to do serious
Tekkit stuff here so get the all the new
materials that you can so we go and make
this nuke I got a bunch of whole do we
need that for nukes
probably yes like Center yes we do
oh I see a diamond oh diamond you don't
see a diamond that's a lie oh wait what
is going on over there my pickaxe broke
and I can't destroy the mob spawner
right oh rutti because i had up to see
what's in the corner you get a bunch of
useless [ __ ] haha cummin wait oh what a
favor
i'm finding diamonds i'm gonna give you
a I'm gonna give you a dirt sward they
made a new level of materials Ertz or
just
I got here just in time to see you die I
am so happy about that
I gotta stop like leaning myself oh all
right oh my god Bob unkar we know what's
happening
he just started why can't I play
Minecraft well danger I don't want to
dig and falling in holes and [ __ ] wait
where are you Alice
shady P how're you wanted me you think
it closer to the microphone Rick I'm
it's right in my nose
you're very quiet Rick while you don't
talk out your nose so there's obviously
I don't I don't know you do when you
talk ha ha ha I know that wasn't that
funny but I thought I'm diamond
where are you final diamond on Oh I
certa skorts yeah see that's what looked
like dime that fooled Wade - I'm just
gonna take I'm gonna call it diamond you
know this drink isn't bad one - get used
to it wait how did you break your
pickaxe so fast he was killing cheese
mousse with it that was not a good life
plan why didn't you use your fists
alright you don't belong here
oh I dropped the courts in the lava oh
oh sorry
probably valuable for probably for like
watches it might maybe be useful dammit
me could make a Swiss action watch or
whatever that little Swiss I don't think
there's a switch action watch swish
Swiss oh my god oh no um it's like that
James Bond stop down here did you guys
go down no there's like train tracks and
[ __ ] yeah I went down there I saw that I
put up some torches around here but
there were zombies I got scared so why
there's torches everywhere yeah I need a
pickaxe too bad alright you know what
wait here come here
oh he's got a shovel damn what hey hey
you're the worst why'd you bring me here
because you're about to help I was found
a whole bunch of coal sweets
Bob you're quiet now Oh is everyone is
Bob is my headset my headset working I
haven't moved you're suddenly so quiet
now I call right now
yeah little better really I was just
screaming and against the microfauna
normal like right then Ted oh my volume
right now no you sound quiet now you
sounded normal when you were screaming
nothing changed what you do right wait
am I going crazy
whoa I am uh I found some fire stuff
wait why would you still wait yeah my
whole thank you I need a pickaxe oh yeah
well I was come you're asking um Rick
Jane there's so much coal here
so much coal everywhere oh yeah coal is
useful in techid uh yeah
guys like putting it bits stupid ha ha
is that oh my bat but I'm saying bat
here yeah wait oh hi yeah that's what I
was fine all right Bob you hang on come
here
I'm gonna I have 36 coal already I'm a
master of this I'm gonna hang on
although yeah there's coal in the wall
why aren't you guys mining things I
don't know X you find more [ __ ] ah don't
move Ted buy a backlog don't move worst
okay you got you got iron armor here
wait where are you I'm gonna give you
stuff okay okay get ready for your dirt
oh all right here you go iron iron gear
for you and take these beds off me cuz
it's I got too many beds I don't know
why I have them we don't really hey if
I'm or God what third beds
the best you guys know it
this I got a red square comeback I know
I don't know what to deal with that but
if you put it all have a big ass oh you
guys are the worst at this game well hey
come here come here
wait oh wait come here all you have to
do all you have to do is say the
greatest person ever I'm an awesome
youtuber I'm good I'm I'm fantastic
benevolent and incredible you guys are
standing right next to a copper block
and you're not mining it wait set it
down
I just need wait come on here say I'm
never saying they say don't get my
[ __ ] listening and to because it's
probably not true you get nothing
oh god here Wonderlab ah I need a sward
to get rid of that ha ha ha ha all right
all right here a 1 sward one pickaxe all
you have to say is thank you Mark
I'm pretty sure he's not gonna say that
how about don't get so it marry close
enough there's one pickaxe to get the
sward you just need to get down on your
knees you know why do you do all the
other time iron get on Jerry you so much
right now and pull the sward from my
hand just hang on let me get a good view
here you pull the sward I'll run my hand
and get it get closer now nowhere y'all
wait get them there nice deep block kids
get in there yeah you want to be a star
don't you take off your pants and get on
the couch you guys suck there we go
great and you do the axe wait more yeah
all right there take your sword oh but
I'll learn and I'm mining it cuz I'm not
a [ __ ]
just gotta I've got the bed ready mark
where you go
the bed you know you just set your spawn
down here in the mine
haha grab you don't go whatever you do
don't fix it for a min let's kill him
every time you get to the upstairs bath
I'm backed by you and I'm not going
anywhere near him wait we're good stay
away from me away from where you were
waited today why do I agree to play with
coz there's one right
oh wait that's the wrong way we want to
go this way oh yeah not that way
oh it's the new way look but I haven't
been oh hey hey actually no it's that
why'd you hit me
I just got 10 Bulls weeks it for you
there's iron here it's important right
we're already like 15 minutes in and
what have we gone speaker I have 10
copper ore
and a bunch of coal why don't ya see
Wade oh there's a whole bunch also paid
all right here one chicken that's you'll
settle yeah Ryan why you want this
sirloin steak marinated in a1 sauce and
seasoned with garlic salt and special
sauce and I mentioned recently my
distaste for your actions Wade's actions
are my actions both of you play the game
okay alright alright where are you Bob
where are you Bob I'm up here mining a
whole buttload of or a buttload a below
to bottom or gone hot butt or that's the
newest thing I'm tech it here's a
bustling I made a blonde [ __ ] I've got
no right I'm going to the surface let me
know when you want to be pulled out cuz
we need to like start doing stuff pull
me out
I didn't go get some torches oh wait
wait needs to pull out quick mark oh
that was that is exactly what you said I
said pull me out on any date you have
marked okay that's nice
Oh out in a network word you're the I
don't even I haven't even been ripping
on you at all wait Bing hey I got it is
hard to do console for that so I oh no I
came to you why I don't know the who's
wrong Hey look bro it's fine should I
destroyed it
okay I'm out of here up up and away
Boosh
oh god that zombie has one of the like
the witch heads that was creepy way no
the witch heads you know if I'm like the
news
that's the the witch things nope no idea
what you're talking about
alright found more lava oh [ __ ] oh no
mark pull me out oh I got ya oh my god
really inches from lava haha fighting a
zombie hahaha every cave oh and it
reserves why I haven't noticed there is
no zombie cam cuz Dobby was unavailable
for this one and we wanted to we've had
trouble getting us all coordinated to
get this in Oh while we're unpacking it
why we're on Tekkit so anyway wait don't
go back down what are you doing you
doofus I'm gonna go finish some
unfinished business I pulled you out for
a reason I'll pull myself back out in it
out and out ah screw it I better make
some chests to put your stuff in Bob Oh
accidentally just took an enormous swig
of this because it's in a bottle hahaha
oh why that made me forget how to drink
my holy [ __ ] how what is it
Oh how's your Jin and Jin doing
oh it's Jenin gin and Diet Sprite damn
dick hey hey hey no swearing kids show
kiss okay how do we make all those
things visit goddamnit Wade you have
your stuff
ten minutes left to build a new you only
gave me one chicken hahahahahahaha
why'd you go back down okay you know
what I'm gonna make a chicken farm and
y'all can shut up
all right just shut up I have him why do
I have a glass block around my head
what's going on watch game why do I play
why do you have a glass plug what what's
hat ask long he's got a helmet on your
head how did you do that what what
haha what's happening uh I don't know
who's he gone yeah it's gone oh there
was you know what in the equipment
drawer on the right side there's some
stuff I had a thing in my thing you had
a thing up stupid rain what if I [ __ ] a
coal in it
what toggle down fall that's weird
I'm lost in the woods again why didn't
you say so earlier
haha so how do I make all of the testing
so we need okay
this Reiter and the whatever yeah
there's that website that's a guide but
we're not gonna do any of that
well what's the point of all the [ __ ]
that I happen what a boy hopefully what
the point exact what anything in these
just words that makes sense
where was that where was that thing yet
I'm gonna go find that portal use it
hang on I need to build a fence fan that
is all fence that drink is awful your
drink is awful
you shouldn't have mixed oh hey your
drink is stupid how do you think the
drink feel do you think I'm talking
about get ready for three two Danza
hahaha oh no I gotta get out yeah
they're gonna pile on each other oh my
god Elle is breaking loose ahaha chicken
bonanza
in a chicken banana ha yeah
where's the mine hole mark where's your
ol October door behind you wait stop
disconnecting
back you're not oh you are back I
thought that said left the game oh my
god these chickens are gonna crash my
computer hahahaha oh I gotta get away
from the chicken feel the chicken are
dolla 400 meters from my Waypoint hang
on I will fight my way back gotta
destroy what I have created my minecraft
is so stuttery hey I get speaking so E
oh I'll get it I'll get it I'll get it
I'll get it I'll get it I'll keep it I
hope I will end the chicken's reign of
terror on again that's the chickens the
chickens
ha ha about what ah ah I took and I come
home you see why this keep crashing ok
you shouldn't be able to get back now
what no there's like two chickens
dropped after all of this episode are
you back Wade I was oh hey there's a
chicken drowning in the [ __ ] water ha ha
oh yeah we should figure out what this
is can you if we're gonna play like that
anyway can you make me a bucket we
figure out what it is yeah yeah yeah of
course I'm gonna flip like this how do
you think I'm gonna play I mean we had
talked about not doing this oh you know
what you may not have been far off here
take that
and dip it in there just shy water dip
it in I was right hahahaha what is it
it's sewage ha ha ha ha they're just
sewage telling I sure don't know what
are you I got TP a diamond in the game
why Jack it's logging in you should you
should explode a whole bunch of holes
like this there's a bunch of orange
stuff over here
oh oh it's a solid rock you like a
hurricane but this is a style of mining
right yeah wait what the explode above
[ __ ] mining side yeah we got wait until
we get the what was that explosive that
we used the Cataclysm the Cataclysm the
thing that just pulled everything and he
tricked me with it
remember how epically I told you but
yeah I know that's why I'm referring no
it's my favorite thing I've ever done it
would really well done I mean next to
like you're very secretive in the
Minecraft stuff because next to the
hiding all the iron in the first episode
of season 2 the thingy that you did
there it would pretty good I really goes
I'm special but we only have five
minutes left
why do we always do this way get over
here we got a we got to do a thing let's
build a house wait what the hell we're
leaving our plenty poppers we gotta go
we got it hang on where are we going
here I'm gonna make some uranium here
here that was easy
wait I don't want change our game over
I'm with if I hang on let's see here you
gonna build us a house out of copper
word your reign oh come on
I can only get nether uranium or what
the hell is that I know what this anyway
just pure have this and a no one have
what here one uranium ore what does it
do it that I've got no tools you're
supposed to stop being such a baby and
with your fists is it working no wait
it's not working is it it's going to
take a new year to do this and I'm not
gonna get anything
Oh got ya guys
oh no I forgot you can go under Oh
you guys are dumb ah okay alright Wow
blob you did a great job here this is
pretty much a nuke yes
pretty close alright aye sir hey wait
here here here here
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
ow
wide wide wide wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait woah wait II baby
wait II baby oh come and take this
pickaxe from me
mine mine until dammit it's you got a
process it I forgot it it doesn't matter
if you mine it process jump in the
sewage ha ha ha
Bob did you see what happened this
episode has not been kind to be i want i
forgot that if you mind nether or the
chance it will explode Oh Bob that's a
lovely looking house yeah no I it's yeah
ok and there's some roots technically it
looks like a skull if you look at it
from a certain perspective actually no
it looks like um in gladiators um the
guy's helmet Russell Crowe's helmet
Russell Crowe's helmet I forget what his
name in the actual movie was but yeah
kind of does oh yes gluteus maximus I
think gluteus maximus Biggus Dickus
what's so funny about the name wait what
are you doing um I had to get out why'd
you fall in what yeah that Wade you ruin
everything absolutely everything alright
so anyway we're we're at the dawn of the
last day here or at the Eve about sunlit
Sun setting on the last day we have here
how old is not accomplishing it
oh my god anything besides beds and a
mound of or it's a house technically we
built a house ha ha ha stupid wait what
the hell where'd you and fall from or
yourself well eight do you have any wood
mark we should put a door on this mofo
yeah you know what I'll do you one
better
I'll just give you a door all right
right oh we spent the first half of this
mining and useless materials just so we
can cheat in the end only useless before
I stuck wait a minute I found something
Bob it's called all war
door okay what did you do I do what does
it do doesn't do anything oh come on
it's just a door well I guess that does
it for today's episode of drunk
minecraft we built the house which is
exactly what we set out to do in the
beginning we with so congratulations
everybody good job Bob you did all right
what where's Weiss anybody watch us do
nothing fun at all shut up wait so thank
you everybody for watching I don't think
we missed anything right did we miss
anything
no I'm I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
okay we got everything so if you want to
see more techy drunk minecraft let us
know in the comments below thanks to get
so many facepalm
remember you can find Wade at Lord
minion 777 on YouTube and Bob at my
scream on Twitter check the links in the
description below so thanks everybody
for watching and as always we'll see in
the next video
but after the copy one
oh my god